[Music]
you've spent a lot of time bouncing yeah
so you get you get a good amount of
practice dealing with
different types of aggression different
types of situations
and i'd like to ask you as a bouncer
two things so number one
if you
defused situations successfully or were
able to de-escalate them were there any
particular approaches or things you
would say that seem to work for that
if you were training a week-long course
for bouncers right the de-escalation
moves or
expressions or questions or whatever you
might use and then when it really just
escalates and you need to take care of
somebody but you don't want to break
your hand or maybe get sued or
whatever it might be what do you do so
if you could just answer those two
that would be great
first of all it's taking the two people
who it starts with take them to the side
don't put it in the gym walk outside
with them do something that they feel
more comfortable and not with everybody
there like for instance with i would be
they really wanted me as a bouncer why
because i could fight no no that was not
the real reason the reason was it that
was came in handy i'm really good with
people from the ten situations nine
times we don't fight because i talk
about of it it's always and the only
thing that i would always use break down
the situation why they got into a fight
and you're gonna find out it's always
stupid
like oh my god
yeah he was looking at my wife i go he
was looking at your wife yeah did you
talk to her no did he touch him no did
he say the regulatory things that did he
make face to ear no no no no did he do
something against you so to to make you
mad no he didn't do that i go that's a
compliment dude i mean that means your
wife is a good looking wife he didn't
overstep he didn't do anything he didn't
touch her and he started looking and got
like yeah yeah i go go
come here and then i would call the
other guy i said did you say something
bad he says no no i was just looking at
his wife and he got really angry you
know
and then they start seeing yeah this is
stupid because it's alcohol alcohol
wants that's involved he makes stupid
mistakes
and once they say okay shake hands you
guys want to drink and i would give him
a beer and the fight was solved so
simply
breaking it down
but in a nice and calm way this is very
important because the screamers will
never work you get them on their toes no
fighting stats no nothing hands down and
and and once you talk to a person always
make sure you look at their hands either
this is the first thing i always tell
people if they put their hands in the
pocket or whatever always expect
something you know it's better to to be
a little bit um
on your toes there maybe get a
handkerchief out it doesn't matter but
always look what they have in their
hands and as soon as they don't have
anything in their hands just take them
outside break the situation down and
they're going to find out it's stupidity
what they're doing and then the fights
it's going to be off there's not going
to be a fight now if there is a fight
and it depends where it is you know if
it's in a in a bar like i put my back
against the wall if there's a corner i'm
with my back in the corner because
nobody can attack me from the sides now
i got my feel perfect view it's going to
be very hard to sneak up behind me you
see so if you have a wall great if you
don't have over the corner corner even
better go into the corner but it depends
again on the situation what's nice get
present and you need to get out maybe
you don't want to be in the corner you
want to go to the exit that you want to
get the heck out of there don't fight if
they have a knife don't let your ego
control yourself you might die i mean
people
do things for no freaking reason you
know simply watch out but that would be
the greatest thing if somebody pulls a
knife you know that's the street
fighting dvd that i made long time ago
the crazy one you know grab grab a box
tool get something that you can separate
him from he needs something in between
it's very hard if i just hold the bar
stool in between for him to come closer
you know it's also very important then
you know that if the fight goes outside
yeah now it's my domain because now i
got space and once there's space
if you start hitting me i won't even let
you hit me and most of the time that is
enough people gotta go [ __ ] if i cannot
even hit him because then i've talked to
them i said good i could have hit you
already i could have hit you alright i
could have hit you again i could have
all right i hit one time in front of his
face you want me to really do this now
let's stop dude i don't want to fight
you know if you say it i don't want to
fight act like you're a little bit
afraid they know you're not but you do
the audience because most of the time
it's egos as well right if i say oh i'm
going to kick your ass now it's an ego
thing he wants to prove himself in front
of everybody who's watching no just
de-escalate by saying dude i don't want
to fight it's so stupid to fight i don't
you oh i could have hit you here already
and nine out of 10 times again
they they realize that you're the guy
with the skill and they're the guys with
no skill now sometimes when it's
absolutely not avoidable anymore yeah
well then you're gonna have to go fast
and especially if there's a weapon
involved thankfully i didn't have those
situations many times because that's a
very bad situation and knife for
instance is really bad almost worse than
a gun like a gun in front of me
i rather have that like when you stand
in my arms reach i rather have that than
when you have a knife a knife is much
more dangerous can cut from every side
especially if it's double bladed very
dangerous gun once you control the gun
in the barrel and you just go with it
and you make sure that you don't put
yourself in the line of fire you know
then everything is okay oh and by the
way gun defenses also make sure that the
loved ones doesn't stand on the side
because if he pulls the trigger that
person is going to go so you have to
situational awareness that's all stuff
that you need to know and then it's
basic stuff like i said if it's without
a weapon if they're standing with the
left leg front they're orthodox that
means the right hand is going to come
nobody's going to throw a hook on the
street everybody's angry everybody loads
up that punch because they're angry you
see so all these things are easy there
people have no clue how easy it is for a
professional fighter it's like me
challenging
a a basket professional basket player to
shoot some hoops who you think is going
to win right i mean come on we do this
every day single day two three times a
day you're not gonna win it's not gonna
happen yeah maybe from the back hit us
but otherwise it's not it's simply not
gonna work you know and if you can bring
that over to them and they realize that
with on top saying i don't want to fight
you know always say you don't want to
fight because that makes you feel good
you know that it's not a threat most of
the times they stop and otherwise it's
the cross counter across comes they
always hit in an angle so that means
they always come from the side so the
only thing you have to do is literally
move backwards because then the punch
already is going to miss you and there's
your counter it's a very simple counter
either a cross or it's an elbow it
depends how close he is but if you learn
distance and that's the first thing we
focus on on your stance and on distance
because distance is everything because
if a person stands here this punch is
not very powerful it's better to go an
uppercut a hook or an elbow in this
distance just for people who are
listening right if somebody is a few
inches from your chest or like within a
foot of your chest yes what i say in
seminars the longer a strike travels the
more power it has the more time it has
to pick up speed and power and i always
use an example with a bow and arrow and
i grab a person in the in the room i
grab a bow and arrow i act like i have a
bone arrow i say if i and i put my hand
against his chest if i let this arrow go
it's going to go in this deep but if i
step back three steps it's going to go
straight through him now i gave it space
and now it had time to develop speed you
see so that's also like if people hit me
on close distance i bring my head closer
to their punches here it hurts but if i
bring my head to the hand he cannot load
up anymore you see i'm cutting off the
distance these little things they're not
going to do anything but if i move away
then he's got reach in order to hit me
hard so distance is everything and
especially when you're backing up and
somebody comes at you
if he comes with aggressive power and
you make the defense but his face is
here you see now a punch is not good you
have to change it to an elbow so that's
why it's always good to have
some classes with people who break it
down like this just a few techniques
it's not that difficult to knock
somebody out but make sure that you
don't have too many techniques just a
few techniques and know them very well
and you're gonna be okay
you